And then lastly, we just wanted to touch upon
some material functionality, slightly more complex again,
but as you'll see, it's very straightforward
if we're layering up these approaches
and learning about each step as we go.
So we'll cover what material functions are,
we'll talk about using function inputs,
we'll talk about building an animated material function,
and then we'll also use that material function
in some form of master material.
So what is a material function?
So material function allows you to embed materials
within materials, avoid an unnecessary clutter.
It also just allows for reuse in various
either projects, packages, multiple materials.
It's kind of reusing that functionality
so you don't have to keep creating
or coding the same thing over and over again.
So if you get a really nice, simple grass wind shader,
for example, in this example,
you've created a really nice water shader
that you really want to reuse throughout your projects.
Material functions are a really nice, clean way of saying,
here's some complex piece of information.
I mean, it can be lightweight,
but generally it'd be something a bit more complex
where you've created this functionality
and you can just use this as a function
to plug into an existing material
to get the desired results
so you don't have to keep reworking existing work.
So we can use function inputs.
So function inputs allow us to create
some kind of customized data
and we can edit the sorting priority,
which allows control on where the new node is
and placed within the material function
and the material destination.
So how to create this is that we want to first create
a material function.
And you can just do this by right clicking
in your content browser,
generally where you'd store other materials.
Maybe you'd create a material function folder specifically
so you know where all your material functions are.
Again, it's just dependent on what your preferred workflow is.
Essentially, you just want to right click
and go to materials and textures
and create the material function from there.
Then you can open it up and create the system.
So this is an in-class exercise.
So we can go through this in the in-class portion.
However, even though there's a lot of nodes going on,
it's definitely not as hard as it seems.
We provided samples and based on the previous example
that we covered in the previous section,
you can see that it's a lot of copy and pasted information.
So we've set up one section and then we just duplicated it
and we're trying to dial in the desired results.
So always just break down the material
to its component parts, kind of work backwards.
And you'll see that a lot of the information
is then duplicated and replicated in different ways
to achieve this result.
And so once we've created that material function,
we can actually just use that
in a different master material now.
So we can select the main material node
and change the material domain to light function.
So this is the main material node here.
So we just want to click this pillar here of inputs
and you just want to, on the left-hand side here,
you'll see that we've got
a light function material set up here
and that just makes sure it casts shadows.
You want to make sure that that's enabled.
And then we can call up the material function in the graph
and we can technically just drag it in.
So if you wanted to select it in your content browser
and drag it in, or we want to specify
that we want to assign this MF four-way motion O2,
if that's what you called it in your project.
So by default, you'll just create a material function
and then plug in the specific function
that you want into that node,
or you can drag and drop it in.
So you just want to, for this example,
you want to create a text quad and a scalar param
to multiply in the material function.
We've used all those before.
And then we want to connect the caustic softer texture
to the texture node and then into the emissive.
You'll see that we've only got
the emissive channel available to us now
because we went into that light function material type.
And so it just accepts emissive colors.
So once we've done that,
we can just connect our light under the light function
in the editor and that should be working
as some kind of caustics style material in your editor.
So just to cover that last section again,
when you have a light in your scene,
all lights, if they're some kind of dynamic light
will have a light function option.
You can just plug this material into that light function
in the details panel,
and that would add a caustics effect to the specific light.
So if you follow along in class
and create this material function, master material,
that will give you a really nice introduction
to master materials.
Again, slightly more complex concept.
It's just getting familiar with each module as you go,
but you'll see that it's a lot
of the replicated information.
You're just building upon your knowledge base.
Try not to let it feel too complex
and just break it down to its component parts
and just build from there.
And then to close out here,
we've just got a few additional resources
if you want to read upon any documentation.
So whether it's the introduction to materials,
animating some UV coordinates,
even just a high level introduction to materials
and material nodes,
all that documentation is available to you.